hello everyone welcome back to PGA chain
design channel this channel is about
sharing rhino3d knowledge to students
and professionals learning Paris right
now 3d technique today what we'd like to
do is to making this tyre ring it's
inspired by car tyre and it has been a
big inspiration for a lot of men's
jewelry are you ready let's get started
before we start this ring let's talk
about some detail about the pattern I
would like to use the pattern is as
simple as possible and try to avoid too
much the sharp angle something like this
I try to fit it a little bit to avoid
the sharp angle but you don't want to
pick up the pattern that's too pointed
and for men's jewelry it's not necessary
to put a lot of stone in there I just
put it there for the decoration so we
won't talk about a stone part but just
about the entire model let's take a look
on the Google search image few things
you may want to avoid first of all the
tire pattern has coming to the point
because now my calls the casting issue
this one is not too bad but the pattern
is too complicated so what we'd like to
do is pick up some pattern is simpler
and doesn't have too much pointed angle
so we are not looking at the actual
attire we want to look at those black
and white image you can click on any of
them and take a look in the detail or
hidden usually going view more so they
are some a very good one like this one
is way too complicated try not to use it
this one you may able to simplify okay
so try not to take something like this
is already have some style on it then
let's go back to right now we want to
start at
view that straw circle Center is at zero
for diameter that's type it 16 here all
right
and then let's go to the right view and
this time we want to make a profile the
profile is the tire basically online so
what I like to do is to create a square
roughly you don't want to get it to why
I think men story if you over a mini
meter it might be too much so somewhere
around a mini meter well be great the
thickness right here we want to set it
up for roughly about three this is still
comfortable if you get it more like a
five millimeter it may not be
comfortable for men's jewelry so I'm
going to move this one to the center
back to where our bring circle is so
let's modify this area a little bit
because I like it to be a come for fit
so what I'd like to do is using the art
to kind of make the inside a little bit
round it's gonna use this one to train
the rectangular that we just create okay
and then on the top I would like to use
the art again to create something a
little bit bigger in the tap and then
use that to trim off the rectangular
again so we're gonna trim off this one
all right so although inside is already
come for fit it's not so comfortable on
those angle so I'm gonna use the fitted
curve to set it up 4.8 in my case that's
run off inside a little bit all right so
on the top I might also want to run it
off as well and you can change the
faded radius to make whatever profiler
you want
once you're done everything that's
joining it and making this ring is very
simple we're gonna use the commands
called sweep one rail and let's go ahead
go ahead to pick up the rail and the
cross section and that's click okay
alright so you may wonder what is that
black line over there
this black line is where the seam is and
this is really important that we move
the seam to inside of a ring shank
because that will affect the create UV
curve if you have a seam it's not right
in the middle okay so let's go ahead to
use the comment it's leaving under the
surface tool and you have this one is
adjust closed surface seen you'll ask
you to pick up the object so let's pick
up this object we don't need to change
both of them so we want to do let's
guess using the U and then we want to
make sure snapping into the quadrant ok
so now the same is right in the middle
so the next step is we need to know
where is the area we want to draw this
tire so let me go ahead to make a line
right there and make sure the line is
really close to where the tangent area
on the top view let me go ahead to copy
and past and hide one of us or we can
bring back later all right
so let's pick up these tooth line and go
ahead and to use the trim and trim off
the extra over there alright so the
reason I'm doing this is because I need
to know where is the area for my tire so
this will be the area that we are going
to work with the command we are going to
use is leaving under the curve curve
from the object
you have create You Vicker so now what
are you seeing here is the area of that
surface and what is coming over here in
this button and the top that is original
the whole ring area and we only want to
design in this rectangular area but we
have to keep all of them for the
reference okay
so let's bring in the tire pattern by
picture picture comment or picture frame
in Rhino 5 we want to bring in the
command right here and the size doesn't
matter at this point we do want to have
a clear image to trace with so with it
is image let's go ahead to trace with
the line I like to use the red colors so
let me create another layer and then
make this layer in the red color so it's
easier for us to see all right so I'm
gonna use the straight line work to
create this sometimes you can hold this
shift and you are able to make a
straight line and because this line is
going to back to align with this so make
sure you a smart track is on and then
you snapping into this point first and
then you can move it back to snapping in
here okay so that's the first one and I
also want to track trace right here and
holding this shift coming back here
holding the shift again then coming back
here alright so now I have this I'm
going to create another curve going from
here to here
and because I want them to be parallel
so I'm just gonna use the gumbo drag it
and hit okie so I will get those two is
parallel the way I'm going to create is
just using the blend tool I'm going to
blend the curve from this point to this
point and then you can adjust it to make
it higher or lower or whatever do you
want on your design okay so let me go
ahead to join those to make it look more
uniform
I was simply just making another copy by
using the rotate tool and using the
gumbo to move it to this side okay so
let's use the Move tool to be very
accurate and snapping into the line
there alright so I got that one and I
also just want to use the mirror tool to
mirror the other one back here and kind
of tilted a little bit too fitting the
design right there so at least they
don't look like they all different and
this they look really similar okay so
now we have all of them just go ahead to
select all curve and that's used a trim
tool to trim the extra
and we're gonna have that one to trim
off this one so now that's joining all
of them oops so now that's join all of
them together all right
so we no longer need this background we
can kind of did it but before I did it
it this background I would like to kind
of mirror all the curves that we have to
the other side just full of reference
we're gonna change it the distant based
on what we have but just want to get an
idea for the propulsion so that's me
roll to the other side now let me delete
the background so it's easier for you to
see all right so now we got those two
curve I'm gonna move it close to our
design and turn a 90-degree over there
and move it somewhere to here all right
so now you can scale bigger or smaller
it really depends on how you like them
close to the edge
okay so I'm going to align them but
before I do that I want to group those
two and I want to pick up my rectangular
shape and let's do the horizontal Center
align and snapping into the midpoint so
on
that way they will align close to the
edge that I like all right so this
looked nice
and then we are going to do one more
things to do a test let's go ahead to
using the array tool it's linear array
and we're gonna array this guy how many
of them I'm not so sure so let's try 25
first and the first reference point is
any of the end point and you can kind of
eyeball for the distance that you like
after you try a few times you find a
perfect gap that you
a lot of time they don't end up exactly
where to match the first one so I would
like to do is instead of to to try to
trim and doing it everything I would
like to do just one D scale this
rectangular so let's go ahead with the
scale one D scale and that's go ahead to
make dis snapping into the end point
alright so we kind of stretch it a
little bit to back to our design but
that's alright because this is the
pattern so it doesn't affect too much
next step let's go ahead to make it into
solid so that's going to desolder tool
extremely plain a curve straight and I
want them to be on the both sides
because I can actually have an
intersection to the ring that we have
and I don't want it to be like too thick
because my ring is already three
millimeter so let's go ahead to set it
about 0.8 millimeter on each side okay
so now we have this all we need to do is
flow it back there before we flow it
back we may want to do some Filat on the
edges to make sure they are not too
sharp first so let's go ahead to do this
we're gonna go into the front view of
review on the top that's use the e felid
and giving a little bit radius that's a
point to all of them okay so now we have
a Fallot and double check to click on
two of them and make sure that they are
closed polished surface okay before you
flow it back to the surface one thing we
wanted to do is we want to H to be
smooth so this is kind of stick it out
and it won't be comfortable for the ring
so you select everybody here
not the curve there and we're gonna use
the command code page edit alright we
want to pick up on the bounding box and
hit enter the XYZ point at this point is
for what we need is actually Y so we
don't have to change anything here and
then very quickly you are going to see
something like this alright it's easier
for us to see on the side view I'm going
to pick at the very end at the right
view and then we scale it down like this
try to get it as close as possible
because that's showing like how much of
the H is going to hanging over there all
right so now our shape has become taper
you can see from our perspective okay
let me change this back to the black
color alright so it probably see easier
so you kind of see it's become a little
bit curved they are tapered there
alright so that will be comfortable for
our rings so that's good them so you
don't have to draw a window all the time
so that's it group them and then let's
fold this back so to fold this back to
the ring I will need to have a surface
so let's go ahead to make this surface
by surface from planar curve alright so
the command we're gonna use is under the
transform you have flow along the
surface we want to pick up this object
and we want to pick up one of the corner
and let's go ahead to pick up one of a
corner in the target alright so it
looked very well but just be double
check to make sure that the ages look
really nice alright so we don't want
this surface right there because we make
a copy earlier and then
go ahead to bring in the copy so now we
have this ring here that's double check
that see the render view and see how
they go this is the tire ring for
today's demonstration I hope you enjoy
it
please like and comment and share my
video that will really help me to reach
more people and share my knowledge thank
you for watching I hope you enjoy and
see you next Monday
[Music]